unless you spent the last 80 years
living in a bat cave you probably
already know a whole lot about Batman
his origins as fancy gadgets and as
Penton for young sidekicks what you
might not know is that an insane series
of events drove Batman to being the dark
brooding vigilante that he is today here
are some of the craziest moments in
Batman's history 0nr in the mid 1950s
Batman began to have interdimensional
and outer space adventures instead of
just fighting street-level thugs and
weirdos so in Batman 113 our hero makes
a strange trip to visit a tattered
multi-colored Batman from Planet sir nr
who needs us Batman's help fighting an
alien invasion though Batman
relationships the rested Zirin are for
his crimes against fashion you just
booked your next vacation row to a
luxurious stay on the set alpha 9 prison
planet if this wasn't strange enough
modern Batman writer Grant Morrison
included the formerly forgotten insane
adventure from Batman zany comics
history into being some kind of trip
into Bruce Wayne's personal
Imaginationland apparently Batman
himself created sir and our Batman as a
backup personality in case he ever went
insane because people can be backed up
like hard drives
apparently bat-mite the following year
in Detective Comics number 267 Batman is
visited from the fifth dimension by an
all-powerful imp named bat-mite who
absolutely worships the dark knight
after all I'm your number one fan
my fan the biggest bat-mite said
something creasing Li strange Challenger
so he can see his hero in action
including making an enormous statue of
Batman himself come to life naturally
Batman is annoyed by having another
little Punk hanging around the Batcave
but the guy persists on enough for the
rest of Batman's career but baby
Batman enjoys dozens of unusual
transformations during the Silver Age
including periods of getting super old
turning into an ape and a tiger and
being a genie however a few changes are
so strange as Batman number 147
transformation into a baby rather than
taking the afternoon off Batman insists
on wearing some suspenders and
continuing to fight crime because if you
thought a man dressed as a bat was
terrifying a violent baby is truly the
stuff of nightmares like can you punch
it in self-defense or what what mah
zebra Batman quick disclaimer as an
Englishman we'd say zebra not zebra I
was asked to record this part saying
zebra so just know that every time I say
zebra I'm dying inside thank you for
your time anyway zebra man most-cited
Batman's period of wearing rainbow
colored outfits as a strangest but his
time as a zebra patterned crimefighter
was even stranger after going up against
zebra man a guy in black and white who
can emit rays of magnetic force
Batman and Robin go to investigate the
criminals lab because Robin is a Darwin
Award waiting to happen he trips and
zaps Batman with the same machine that
gave zebra man his powers also giving
him a similar suit in the process as
usual Batman literally punches the
stripes off of zebra man and everything
returns to normal
well relatively normal death of Robin
after the Silver Age ended the ones
carefree Batman of the 60s became darker
everything reached a boiling point by
1988 a death in the family The Joker
kidnaps Robins estranged neglectful
mother beats Robin nearly to death with
a crowbar and sets off a bomb readers at
home were given the chance to call the
DC Comics hotline and let them know if
they thought Robin should survive or go
after the Batcave in the sky and a
slight majority of overwhelmingly bitter
nerds decided that Robin should bite the
big one
Robin dies and Batman sets out on a
darker grimmer path from which you'll
never work
thanks geeks Killing Joke because the
Joker is on a mission to destroy
everything that Batman loves he goes on
as much malicious and personal crime
spree in bat history in The Killing Joke
the Clown Prince of Crime shoots Barbara
Gordon also known as Batgirl and
paralyzes her permanently before
kidnapping her father Commissioner
Gordon the Commissioner has kept naked
in a cage of circus freaks and forced a
look at images of his daughter naked and
in agony from a gunshot wound
Batman's entire world continues to fall
apart and his real insanity begins to
show through venom after accidentally
letting a little girl drown Batman
starts to use a strength enhancing drug
called venom knowing that it's a bad
idea but willing to do anything to
prevent another death after realizing
that his addiction is sending him into
an irrational rage and doing more harm
than good
Batman locks himself in a basement for a
month and detoxes by sheer willpower
because damn he's Batman but a
recovering Batman is still a sight to
behold night for two years later a
criminal named Bane gets a hold of the
same drug that Batman was previously
abusing and used it to enhance himself
enough to snap Batman spine
but only after releasing all of the
criminals and Arkham to wear down the
Caped Crusader into a state of total
exhaustion
Batman remains paralyzed for a while
while the violent protege of his takes
over the Batman named and causes the
wrong kind of chaos for Gotham's
criminals totally messing up the Batman
brand even worse than this guy Batman
wets his pants if there's a single
moment in Batman's history that has no
right to exist including this it's Kevin
Smith's comic tale in which Batman wets
his unit I'll because he stands too
close to an explosion because Smith
lives in a world where adults regularly
cannot control their body functions
Smith drags the Dark Knight into
unforgivable territory he only makes it
worse by openly discussing Batman's
bedroom habits and making Catwoman have
a temper tantrum when she learns up
Bruce is getting married Bob should have
stayed silent on this one
zapped through time Batman's time-travel
adventures from the Silver Age make a
comeback when supervillain Darkseid
shoots to hero with his Omega beams
normally these beams a razor victim from
existence but this time they send Batman
back to the Stone Age where he lives as
a caveman for a while before slipping
through other eras in which he's a witch
hunter of pirates a cowboy and the 1930s
detective when Bruce Wayne eventually
stumbles back into present day after his
epic journey the Justice League has to
stop his heart to prevent dangerous
Omega energy from destroying the world
anyhow he survives cuz Batman is the
most badass superhero ever thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which moment in Batman's
history you think is a craziest
[Music]